I don't know if you've heard but some
people are saying that our Kelly might
have had sex with underage women did you
hear about this I heard that yes I'm
saying it literally allegedly this is
alleged this is very only years ago I
heard a back in late 2004 may it is
starting to rise to the surface again
slightly yeah by the way they want we
didn't mention this before the break
yeah
they the the proverbial the powers that
be the powers that be desperately want
our Kelly in jail he sees back in jail
now because a child $1,000 in child
support and they know if he had to spend
three days in jail because he couldn't
come up with $100,000 for bail where the
[ __ ] is he gonna come up with another
$160,000 for child support they know
anything in the interview where he goes
uh he's just going on his rant he goes
they try to take me from my kids yeah he
was trying to say his actual children
but for a pedophile yeah poor choice of
words yeah not that the statement you
want to put out there he was back on the
news this morning
uh-huh you know cuz as we said it before
the break CBS is really is milking this
thing it's right there doing CBS is
doing what you're doing was views from
the cysts they're like we got all this
content yes what are we doing dropping
it all in one lump sum let's drop a
little today a little tomorrow keep them
tuned in yeah so that's what they're
doing and I've heard again we have
handsome Rob has been on top of this
he's been fantastic cuz we don't want to
wait till the next day to cover this we
want to cover it day of right so we're
hearing these clips for the first time
but we already have them this is the
stuff that aired this morning okay on
CBS this morning
okay um are Kelly and Gayle King part
two of their interview are Kelly talks
about his money of course this is after
what we saw yesterday when our Kelly
starts to standing up spazzing out
looking directly at the camera shouting
about being taken away from his children
I believe when we last left our Kelly he
had accused the world of trying to bury
him alive but I'm still yeah he
whispered a lot you remind me the way he
acted during that interview actually
Scatman Crothers and One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest I know it's a very creepy
weird reference when they're all the
[ __ ] mental patients are in his
office
no okay well I I would say Cuckoo's Nest
is a little bit more appropriate to
reference than most of what you usually
do so I'm okay with that okay yeah do
you remember the scene I don't okay
Thomas if eclis but someday Cuckoo's
Nest is a fabulous it sure is fabulous
tragic ending I only watched the first
part alright let's go art Kelly talking
about his money with Gayle King your
income it was reported that your income
was very high hundreds of millions of
dollars we'll say that because I don't
want to get hung up on this man Bob wish
that was true and yet when you were in
jail last week the bond was a hundred
thousand dollars and they said our Kelly
couldn't even afford to get himself out
of jail that a friend had to come in
Vail you out of jail
what is your financial situation if you
don't mind saying here's the deal so
many people have been stealing my money
people was connected to my account I
went into I went by myself for the first
time to Bank of America didn't know what
I was doing didn't know what the hell
was going on when did you do that first
time by yourself three weeks ago okay
come on
like I these artists to sit there going
like I can't believe everybody's
stealing for me you went to the bank for
the first time three weeks ago you're in
your 40s
what are you doing I've never taken a
person to the bank go to the bank know
who the [ __ ] wants to go to the bank
with you yeah and how long ago is that
three weeks yeah that's that's why
they're stealing your money musicians
get ripped off all this all the [ __ ]
time musicians boxers yeah that's great
it's gone being an easy mark if you're
gonna sit there and not look at your
money and not know how the bank works in
your 40s when you're a millionaire yeah
you got to take that L there's a there's
a did you guys watch the surviving our
Kelly documentary yeah okay did you
notice that all his music was playing in
it
Yeah right can one know why that is cuz
this [ __ ] idiot doesn't own his
masters none of them know that's why the
docs slapped because they weren't
playing the b-sides right they know hey
hot [ __ ] yeah cuz he doesn't own any of
it so these idiots that are like mute
are Kelly you know that hashtag yeah
play him he's not making any money
anyway yeah oh my god
right that's why he's so broke it's like
a lot of these guys that own like with
Michael
he owns of course I think he owns half
of all Sony or something crazy at the
Beatles cattle the Beatles catalog and I
think even more so getting him a card to
get it back now yeah well known to be
fair Michael doesn't own anything after
he's dead he's dead that is true yes the
point is that as a George there's one
pair of tiny Underpants safe coat yeah
the coroner just couldn't pry these out
of his hands so rigor mortis set in
while he was clutching what time is
blueberry Palmer's even every sure yeah
Paul Versys welcome to join us
yes like so so Kelly is but you would
think it competent with this [ __ ] man
are Kelly is it's not even like he's one
of these pop stars the pop stars that
sit there and kind of have their songs
written form that are just a creation
yeah somebody else is writing the song
somebody else is making the music and
you're just plugged in seeing how we
tell you to sing when they end up with
nothing you kind of go yeah I mean they
weren't really your masters to be
playing with you're just a piece of the
rock but our Kelly is a musician and a
songwriter these are his creations other
musicians go to art Kelly and say teach
me how to do right ahead maybe Mark
Kelly to not own his own masters is
crazy yeah maybe it's hard for us to
like accept somebody could be so elite
at one thing and that not trickled down
to anything else you know what I like an
athlete that's so good at basketball and
we're like maybe you don't know how to
do finances adult you only know
basketball look I can't even walk and
chew gum at the same that's it you have
to make sure you in charge you um I'm
[ __ ] so careful I sign every check no
one realizes checks but me I'm are Kelly
I have no clue what's going on get out
now I have a business manager named
Carlos signs your checks this is your
power of attorney I'm sure they probably
all do
I've given no one power but you're not
even 100% sure I'm not honest I would
call Carlos after this show the
undiscussed powerpreter
but one time I called and it just I got
the this number is no longer in service
and I was like oh they got me
like I'm
forget me I think they're waiting for me
to make enough money to get them do you
drive check your accounts yeah so I
stood day I'm like financially
illiterate so I make them send me a
financially illiterate statement right I
go just tell me how much in the
beginning a month in the end they're
like yeah but there's expenses I go no
no no how much at the in the last month
in this one and then I calculate and I
just ask questions like why is it less
than this one what we dint deposit yet
okay keep it up I get deposit sent from
the radio JA sure and certain like you
know gauge will send a deposit but that
type of stuff goes to the agents but
most checks any checks written to the
government to anybody else I have to
sign if it comes so you go to their
office they send me a FedEx with all my
bills and I sign the checks and I have a
record of everything I saw hey buddy so
you don't have to go to Carlos's house
no when I make sure I do that because
they're not you know if there's anything
weird I'll ask him that's maybe that's
smart I guess there's part of me that's
trying to whatever is he but this tryna
just like isolate the I get the whole
reason I did it was like how do I have
more time to just create I feel so
spread thin with [ __ ] let me tell you
accountants will really they're really
good at freeing up your time and sure
let them no problem do you know what to
pay attention to your money we got it
shouts no problem keep creating your
bills I need some money to create sorry
but I watched it all go away I keep my
eye on everyday you guys got me freaked
out yeah I would I would get power it
don't get power of attorney to anybody
do you tell use on your own channel it's
the Paul versus here by the way Paul
virzi who his first TV special just came
out and spoke bill burr presents Paul
virzi I'll say this and it's available
to stream on Comedy Central's website
that's amazing no thanks man thanks for
having me
good to see you yeah now yeah you got
you got Comedy Central money coming in
yeah Dober presents money coming in are
you watching this money are you Andrew
Schultz hanging up and going you know
what
I'm sure Carlos has it taken care of
here no I got I got a wife and two kids
so she takes you know she just yes yeah
and plus you she'll do it better than
I'll do it
I very recently put my wife in charge of
the
you have to to the point where now Jess
will go like hey Sam like what do you
want to do in terminus mine into a
different account so we can take care of
this bill I go Jess this is on you just
do it I need you to take ownership of
this thing that's the one person I'm
supposed to be able to trust right I
married this person and a child by this
person yeah like you could take care of
the finances it's certainly better than
Carlos I think you know you never know
you don't know you know you don't know
my bags you're right when I got your
wife is behind you're right you don't
know you like you're not responsible for
Carlos's hobbies that's true exactly
yeah exactly that's our I just as long
as I look through the statement I don't
see any kind of hobbies there when
Carlos rolls up with some new shoes on
for example we don't do new shoes call
us a simple guy any day sure yeah if
you're into the fancy stuff we can't we
like simple clothes and the Bahamas
likes very simple clothes and Swiss bank
account walked in here you know last
legs very simple clothes Freeway Ricky
Ross yeah you know who's making millions
of dollars on the side that's right
freeway Ricky Ross right now no but at a
time he was doing quite well financially
right business was lucrative so way you
don't sign your own bills you don't pay
your bills no they do everything smart
the way it operates is they they get a
percentage of the income so it's in
there but right now it's rather than 100
understands money thinks this is stupid
right yes but the way that I'm the way
that I'm viewing it is like as I like
scale up to business right there's
people that I'm paying right like so it
there are other podcast guys that I'm
doing work on sort of putting them out
like you know we're starting an ad
agency for podcasts and I want to be
able to pay the employees of that and so
I can't personally sign all those checks
right and do is I have to have some sort
of structure bill and a certain point
time you need to trust people and it's
like what Rick Ross said Ricky Ross said
he's like look people are gonna steal as
long as they don't steal a lot yeah you
can sign all the checks there's not that
many checks design and also employing
people alright you could have one
account that deals with that like that
they have power of attorney
you're actually you actually are
supposed to have a business account that
isn't also your whole account right
Carlos in charge of the business account
yeah and maybe you go Carlos I think
there was a personal account I can't be
r.kelly walking into a Bank of America
for the first time at 48 I just found
out before you walked in we were playing
in clips of our Kelly on CBS news just
from this morning and Gayle King was
asking him about his financial situation
in fact he couldn't afford to get
himself out of jail his friend had to
bail him out and he said he found out
everybody's been stealing from him and
he found that out because three weeks
ago he went into the bank for the first
time in his life can't read all right
Kelly's illiterate still they talked
about that in the dock yeah he's can't
read there's a I mean my buddy shouts
the cipher sounds cipher point this out
to me he's like he's like he's a kid
he's broke and I'm like what you talking
about you know he's broke he is that's
why the stories are coming out what are
you talking about he goes listen when
you want it when somebody like in this
famous touched you you don't go to the
cops first Yeah right you voted a famous
person for money yeah you got to get
that money
so yes given 20 grand out to everybody
20 grand and all of a sudden it's like
are Kelly imprison me in this place
Chris makes any stories start to come in
here something mentally wrong with him
like when she was talking to me can't
comprehend like he's definitely there's
some real issues with this guy mentally
yeah the first video I saw it told me
that 2004 saw that video because it's
porn yeah you're not even see it went
around everywhere it was everything it
was online everywhere it wasn't hard to
find no I remember there was the video
of the guy getting [ __ ] by the horse
sure but your hand you had a funny bit
about it thank you stay single huh
thank you all right so it's like but
that's why Channel single he
old enough to get [ __ ] his name was he
was the boy your husband was he was
[ __ ] to death my horse you know we're
talking about die idiots and then how we
all feel like geniuses when we win our
Callie unfortunately does not feel like
a genius cuz he realized that he went to
the bank and he has no money because
people were stealing from him
let's go back to the clips this is from
this morning on CBS Gayle King talking
to our Kelly about his financial
situation America by yourself by myself
because I was so tired of not knowing
where my money was what my publisher is
isn't that what knew then that you
didn't know what your money is a lot of
it's on me and people say he doesn't
have money because he had to pay so much
in settlements what do you say about
that
my favorite response oh yeah King was
[ __ ] great though I mean she's
incredible she was really ballsy and you
know that he chose Gayle King cuz he
figured you know a lot of black women
like our Kelly I'm sure that our Kelly
is like I'll do one interview and I'll
do it with Gayle King yeah as he thought
Gayle King would go easy Gayle King they
may have met already over the years I
bet they did you know Gayle King has
been in show business for a long long
time but she's like you might have
forgotten are Kelly I'm actually a
legitimate journalist and I'm gonna do
an actual interview with you also I'm
not infatuated with you because I think
you probably had sex with a lot of
underage people you know how much is he
loving the Michael Jackson dock he came
in and did this interview after the
doctor mania I speculated that he did
that because it was it was like the
Shonda he knew
kind of be in the shadow of that giant
once we could kind of get it out but
guess what it's probably more no because
the Michael Jackson docks suck compared
to this man yeah it was like just two
guys and part two was not that great it
was just too much on I it wasn't enough
about it wasn't enough Michael Jackson
dock was fun for Monday yeah this is
there's some meat on this okay that's a
nice shank man yeah uh yeah that the
Michael Jackson dock and this really
shows you that like the genius of Oprah
because Gail is an Oprah shibata's horse
and they're owned this last couple weeks
oh yeah they did
these interviews though it's so weird
after show for HBO oh yeah she did but I
mean she's not getting art Kelly she
could if she wanted she wanted but she's
like all right Gail you handle that
we're taking all the pedophiles out all
the pedophiles out this weekend Taylor
Lee we're kind of the ones that put them
on the pedestal that allowed them to be
these super pedophiles to begin with
what they did I think Michael Jackson
was it was like Oprah's interview those
were loved Michael Oprah Oprah put
Michael way up on the pesto oh he was
famous long before Oprah though I mean
and right but I mean Oprah really yeah I
didn't realize that she put him up there
like that oh yeah quote she loved
Michael Jackson oh yeah
but Julie I mean Michael was I'm not not
to say Michael wouldn't been famously
the biggest selling album of all time
was long before she came around what
year to the Oprah starter show it was in
the 90s mmm I think over started in 1968
Oh like news business in Baltimore and
that's where Oprah got her start and
this is like way back before it was
Oprah and a buddy of his used to get
head from Oprah
at the office really and allegedly
allegedly and allegedly said to my pops
um bro this chicks gonna make it for
some reason my dad remembers that story
like he's got memories that are foggy
now forgets a lot of [ __ ] hasn't
forgotten Oprah's head skills Wow
incredible well let's go back to the CBS
interview this is when so remember I
said just before the break that if
you're gonna put out your girlfriend's
to announce that like you're a good guy
you're not this pedophile guy who's
keeping women hostage that just to make
a
America side with you maybe just bring
out one girlfriend don't announce hey
these are my two girlfriends yeah
because most of America is already like
nuts to women saying they're your
girlfriends and defending you like on
Wednesday you go I don't have a harem
that's ridiculous I do not have a harem
on Thursday you go here to defend me are
two of my girlfriends and you're going
okay huh I don't know if you know what
harem means then but he talks about here
with Gayle his relationship with with
his girlfriends up with them it's like
my girlfriend's it's like and I know
guys like I've known guys all my life to
have five or six women okay so don't go
to hell me okay cuz that's the truth the
fact that they're much younger than you
I don't look at much younger than me I
just look at legal I just look at boys
for a sec yeah like people I just look
at legal like when you have to go and
say wait before I start is she of legal
age when you are just getting in right
at the right at the line yeah it's
there's still some suspicion there when
you have to go before we do this I have
to make sure it's legal I would say most
people yeah like I know that this is not
illegal when your dick is out you're
saying or what time of day was born so
don't go there they're dudes that have
multiple in their whole life right
no absolutely yeah but they're not on TV
trying to justify a horrible actions
good point right the fact that our Kelly
might have multiple girlfriends yeah
least of his concerns in this moment yes
it's not a problem no that's not that's
not the issue is that some of the
quote-unquote girlfriends might have
been held against their will and also
word teens apparently underage teen he's
a mesmerizing guy like will you watch
him talk you like I understand why
people like license yesterday why people
enjoy listening to him yeah I imagine if
you're a woman in Europe
of his music and then oh that guy's
captivated I mean come on if you can't
read your whole life has been verbal
communication you probably not writing
anything is it does he really expect
people to believe that he's sitting
there going you know what I find
attractive women who are legal yeah
that's that's the first thing I don't
pay attention to a date yes legal legal
yeah are you an adult by this state's
definition of the law and then us do you
membership pal I just thought this funny
story my grandma remember Chapelle did
did this you do the sketch the PM was
getting peed on
yeah my my little Greek grandmother
walked in and she sees the and it was
like the girls just getting peed on
she's going like this my grandmother
just goes oh is it raining explain to
you Nana no it's not here's what you
don't want her nota you know her to walk
in golden shower but it was wild right
okay so there's something that when I
was watching that like changed my my
whole perspective on this sounds like a
weird sentence pedophilia still think
it's wrong but uh I used to think that
oh yeah these people are attracted to
kids I don't think anybody's attracted
to kids anymore
I think they're attracted to the the
power dynamic with a kid where a kid
looks at you like you're God
oh yeah right and that's why he was able
to get whacked off by the dad right
because his sexual attraction or the
thing that turned him on was cued by
complete dominance over a human being
right right and then that's why I was
able to [ __ ] his wife well he knew the
dad was gay he knew the dad was gay and
preyed on that anymore but he wasn't gay
like right so but the Farrah no he could
get up be me was just sexual yeah
the dad was not attractive so now that
that was a five
our situation right my boy pointed out
one of the chicks in his harem was
thirty right yes so it's like for him
and this goes even into like pedophile
priests [ __ ] it's like Oh does it do
just going into the Catholic religion
make you a pedophile no being a
pedophile makes you go into that
searching for that power cuz you're
looking at the person your community who
everybody looks at up to as God yeah oh
I want to be that because I need this
kind of love and affection
so I anyway it's just a different way to
kind of look at it so you think that a
fruit you think that like a guy that's
like nineteen twenty and wants to go and
be a priest in his mom not all not all
at all right but you're saying the ones
that are do that yeah I don't think
they're going to that for that yes
they're like because everybody that's
going to be a priest on some level it's
like they I imagine on some well no you
you truly love God and you want a
service but people who want a position
of power right want it for a reason like
it's one thing to if you want a service
guide you want a service God if you want
a service God on a level to put you
above other people and that's something
that inside you yeah there's something
there I also think some of those guys
want to think that's gonna they can
escape their demons there too that's
true I think a lot of guys think it will
cure them or like that you know maybe
God can save me let me get close to the
person that can really change and I'm
not saying that everybody that goes to
be is a that goes to be a priest of bad
words I've friends that are you know
pastors that I better like right off yep
so much yeah I don't know I don't have
what the presenters but that's a that's
a great point so you're going to cure it
right what do you think it'll just save
you from what I've saved even it doesn't
save you but now you're in there was
position where all the sudden you've got
all this power mmm to do the kind of
wild [ __ ] that you were trying to run
from right if there's something curious
going on so cuz are Kelly can bang this
30 year old and these 18 year olds at
the same time let's listen to our Kelly
talked about his girlfriend's that he's
deeply in love with because they're
legal
I don't know if you had a relationship I
don't know what you know I don't know
but one might be older than the other
one might be younger than the other okay
so I just look at legal okay
people they are older men that like
younger women is that younger women that
like older me are you a older man that
likes younger women come on old a man to
love all women okay listen to that oh
yeah
sexual and yeah but by the way that was
honest that what he just said oh yeah
yeah let me drag out the word all in an
interview you're trying to save your
reputation yeah that's just snuck out I
love all [ __ ] why did I say that
licking his lips looking at Gail I love
all women Gail and this is where our
Kelly so one of the defense's he's
saying is that the women that were being
quote-unquote held captive he said he
bought them from the parents bought them
I believe that he is saying that so I
mean it's like you know if he bought him
he bought him that's fair fair is fair
that's true and you should talk to the
parents absolutely he's bringing up the
the the parents here yeah in one of
these actual speak to the merchant
that's right so looking for a Jocelyn
Savage I was doing my show he brought
her and asked a friend of mine to put
her on the stage with our Kelly make
sure she's on the stage as real Clary
what can you tell what is your
relationship with her right now
I'm seeing her you were seeing her she's
21
I'm seeing her she's 21 but you know
you're in trouble when you're for the
record 21 and I'm seeing her like when
age comes first before you ask why is
she the one from the documentary that
let left to do it that they found on TMZ
or no he's a different girl I think
that's a different girl I think that as
real doctor was heartbreaking the girl
her mom came and rescued her yeah and
then at the act and then three days
later she went back to our Kelly but
after that she went back home yeah
that's good which made me feel good yeah
I'm not sure people do escape I mean I
mean like abusive situations
if there are abusive elderly I don't get
sued for saying that she might have
escaped administration I think I can
hold up in court oh sorry are okay did
you start seeing her at 17 only not did
you have sex with her when she was 70
absolutely not absolutely not although
her parents wanted me to know her last
thing they have text messages that show
that you had sex with her with 17 oh so
you're saying you did not have sex with
absolutely not
can we look up as real Clary true I want
to see what she looks like so I'll know
her face yeah she the one that went to
the pool party remember that one that
was describing going to the pool party
who was hanging out outside the
courtroom during our Kelly's first case
I remember the one had very very short
hair at the end with the little baseball
hat and they and they took her
I remember her yeah that was the one is
that the who's the one that mom came in
rescued her that was her with it but she
cut off all her hair and was wearing a
baseball hat wasn't she's that as real
Clary I think so no she's back with him
I guess so
what is he crazy what is uh what does
Cal's do next
Cal's is talking to Gayle King on CBS
and he been she talks about you know the
the concert stuff that he would have
girls onstage with him at the concert
they would come backstage with him and
then all of a sudden he's leaving the
concert with the kids and the parents
that brought the kids are like yeah what
happened to my kid so I guess he's
addressing in here yeah you were with
two women right now you love them they
say they love you what kind of love is
it that keeps these these young women
away from their families their families
are zombies I'm talking right now about
jobs because you know answer your
question what kind of father
what kind of mother will sell they
daughter to a man who did that how come
it was okay for me to see them until
they wasn't getting no money from it why
would you take your daughter if I was
gonna take my daughter and she's 19
years old to a 49 year old icon whatever
celebrity say icon star icon and leave
take it to the concert their father is
more into my music and know about my
music than they do
you're saying the parents handed their
daughters a Jarell and joseline over to
you is that what you're saying to us
absolutely
[Music]
interviews let's not film this yes we
have to say anything
[Laughter]
through line with you know duck template
site the Michael Jackson thing and this
it's like completely incompetent parents
yeah oh my god I thought what the in
place site was actually that was that
was criminal yeah well I mean distracted
he's [ __ ] joking a guy off by the way
I submit that he sucked it - I got a
stiffy no way the father is [ __ ] I
guarantee a Bob bobs big hand we're
gonna back a [ __ ] dumpees head he was
like all right dig it was a one-time
deal no no no no no me neither he did
sexual acts with both parents and I
think that that's what he was holding
that was kind of why they were you know
he had that power over there any night
yeah he blackmailed the they all tell
them everything so they
their daughter just gotta be terrible
terrible parents even the Michael
Jackson stuff the Michael it's so clear
when you're talking to those moms if you
believe those documentaries dude both of
those bombs wanted to be able to hang
out with Michael Jackson wanted their
kids to be able to get up on stage with
Michael Jackson and they ignored every
telltale sign sign that illuminated for
me was one of the moms says this yes
yeah Michael Jackson befriended us us
exactly that's right day she says us
wait Robson's mom was saying in the docs
she goes no Michael and I had a
completely different relationship than
Michael and Wade and then she says when
Michael died she clutched a Michael
Jackson jacket and just cried and cried
and cried for hours she also said that
she didn't want to know the sexual is
that the one who says she didn't know
the sexual who's the Australian lady she
didn't want to know any of the sexual
stuff I'd have nightmares well it's like
he has to deal with it yeah what a
selfish awful woman yeah the one who
doesn't like you bro baby was she's a
country yeah what a [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
want to help you know Mike what makes
these guys the most sick though is like
the [ __ ] they do before they actually do
the sexual life the way they like kiss
him on the head give him kid grooming
and then and then all this and then it's
like I could trust this guy this guy
gave me cotton candy and put me on a
[ __ ] roller coaster yeah and he's
taking care of my family
and then oh yeah and then we're gonna
hop in bed lay down together and then it
just starts like that and he's and I
think they like still like love him in a
way which is [ __ ] crazy yeah when
they were the first 30 minutes I turned
after 30 minutes but before they really
talked about any kind of sexual [ __ ] it
seemed like they were reminiscing on the
best part of their [ __ ] life well the
kids loved him yeah I think you know I
can love them I mean they're still on
some level you took to wait by the end
of the thing he's like yeah I was like
sexually abused but on some level he
still looks at Michael Jackson as his
first love yeah 100% is easy on he'd you
know when you're that young he gives you
happens dude MJ might how gentle s for
the dancer bro the fact that like I
still got that connection in these
[ __ ] kids eyes yeah like and they're
they're both straight well here's a big
start is when you when you're when you
god there's an aura and it's kind of
hard but if he was a regular guy he's a
trucker who's Michael Jackson the
[ __ ] guy that worked for UPS
part-time I think it's safe to say would
you guys agree this is the most famous
person of all time
Michael Jackson I mean who Jesus Michael
yeah I mean it's slicer yeah right big
ones yeah I mean yeah I would say but in
terms of pop-culture people Michael and
Elvis where are the people yeah I would
even give Michael the edge over I would
probably - Elvis was there before but
Michael for long after yeah Michael had
way longer of ironic Elvis wasn't in
Asia right well no I think he was
listened to in Africa they probably know
who he is though yeah buddy the entire
world was focusing on one human being
like if he went to Japan and Beatles if
he went to Africa it was beat it like it
was how about this Michael has the whole
world looking at him and he's still able
to molest yeah you talk about a lens on
you can you believe that you created
smooth criminal' greatest molester of
all time any thoughts on them and walk
them around in public holding their hand
and like oh that's not cute yeah pulled
it off he dressed him up like him and
walked him around non-stop the whole
world's watching and notice they said it
needed to go with Macaulay Culkin he's
abducted in plain sight that like
Macaulay Culkin was there apparently
right and he didn't do anything with him
but maybe he knew he's like listen his
kids with that famous and Corey Feldman
is the same deal didn't do anything with
Corey felt was jealous did you see that
[ __ ] jealous he was so [ __ ] he's
like if he couldn't if he didn't do it
to me why would he do it to anyone else
yeah III you know yes good no you say no
no no I don't have a joke I had a
thought go it was like when you it was
almost like when you're formulating a
joke and you think the parts are coming
together in front of you a beautiful
mind that didn't happen there right know
any part just flew right by to all the
other parts are around two parts floated
I just stared out there watch them go
away fool goddamn fool on live radio all
right do we we didn't finish that clip
that retired did we know okay this is
this is our Kelly did we the concert
clip we played yeah okay this is our
Kelly now talking about his child
support which this interview was
obviously filmed on Tuesday mm-hmm 24
hours removed from the interview he
would be arrested for said child support
isn't that interesting $160,000 but our
Kelly talks about it here how can I pay
child support how if my wife is
destroying my name and I can't work how
can I work how can I get paid your
ex-wife being married I flew in on a
helicopter
I mean helicopters are cool oh sure
you know up and down like that crying
seems like acting and why we should be
making fun of him he's a vulnerable man
this is in his weakened state he's I
mean for God's sakes guys yeah the man
flew in on a helicopter a helicopter you
believe this dude I reminds me that Bill
burr choking the helicopter mouse was
the loudest I've ever laughed while
watching something on TV what was the
joke the helicopter riding with him he
did but about the butcher but this guy
you know this is a great story we're
driving no Andrew we're driving from El
Paso to San Antonio me and his and I go
like this this is how we're driving from
El Paso to San Antonio like four years
ago you know and three years ago and I
just go do did you hear about that I
heard the story about that guy that was
giving hot helicopter tours over Orange
County and he just showed up alone he
got to 500 feet he opened the door and
he jumped the [ __ ] out and Burt I just
see his real swegles what do you think
he goes dude what do you think the pilot
was thinking right so then he goes oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] he starts doing it
and I watched him I do you got to do
they're not because when we would be on
TV like you do that on stage I'll do
this you promise like that you know a
growing thing and I go you got to do
that stage you die was so funny and he
did it and he just did that part but
then he did it from both perspectives
and then by the time the tour was over
he had the whole thing he had but the
guy was supposed to go up in a
helicopter with his wife and then he
said that he was gone with two but his
whole plan was to kill himself right so
he said all the other person didn't show
up but here's the kicker the helicopter
pilot just got the company handed to him
after 40 years from the yeah and the guy
jumped out so he went he guy what got
there is again why the other person's
not coming got to 500 just looked over
and just and just went and he's like so
right now you can see the law said put
your seat back on the craziest thing is
the guy lived he lived and he died in
the hospital he broke he with yeah he
brought him there they brought him a
mess oh wow the act out of him falling
and he goes he goes
four more seconds to tell I'm happy
three more seconds until have to deal
with this [ __ ] anymore
oh man visionary
alright let's rewind just a little bit
so we can hear about our Kelly's a
helicopter and how he can't pay child
support because of it being married
I flew in on a helicopter helicopter
yeah can somebody is miss informing him
of something I'm gonna leave he said no
you're doing well the guy next to him
said you're doing well like y'all king's
producer the same guy probably the same
guy that signs our Kelly's checks
yeah I'm convinced and sitting there
going like no you're doing great you're
doing awesome I flew in on a helicopter
what a damn puppy I suppose I was in
love with Tula Hey look I make mistakes
I'm not perfect we got married okay
we had three beautiful kids not once
have I ever had a domestic violence call
at the house and all this than the other
it never happened okay
I mean that's much romantic thing I've
ever heard in my life yeah brings a
puppy on a helicopter flew in on a
helicopter with a damn puppy huh I mean
come on I believe them does this guy
sound like a bad guy to you I believe
that story that story hundred percent oh
yeah I mean you know how much you have
to do to make up for the fact that it
might be pissing on underage women yes
like that real you really have to charm
a girl at that point not being a
helicopter will help you might never
want to know I propose you put your dog
[ __ ] dog back on the helicopter and
take off
Millie ating kids though because that
would impress a kid oh my god I don't
know what brain work it's just like we
get candy canes in there too it's
amazing it's incredible I got about a
bag full of gobstoppers - amazing that's
a very romantic way proposing to your
wife who checks your bank account with a
helicopter and a puppy yeah you know
your [ __ ] mind and Jess good news we
also got a dog what is a returnable
puppy I want to go to Lancaster and get
one from a puppy mill cause they're
really that's where the best place to
buy them you like Bobby Miller yeah I
see I see
[Laughter]
I believe that is Robyn there with you
Travis yes yes so does Rob think that
this last clip is best to be played
through audio or video I'd do video okay
Troy why don't you hook us up with the
video because Rob said that the visual
was terrific yeah I sent Roy the link
good for you Rob yeah very dutiful very
dry very dutiful young man unfortunately
we are dealing with a little operator
error here trash trash trash trash trash
who's your garbage why would I delete it
he just sent you the clip and you
deleted it I don't know he said it to
you during the break and he was like
here we might do this and you're like an
executive decision nah [ __ ] it [ __ ]
got robbed on the pay no mind list yeah
he does it's worse than the pain Oh Mike
there nobody just resent it nobody your
inbox yeah try the inbox
yep oh right there no wait right no it
looks inbox
bago perfectly refresh sorry you may be
the worst person ever operate a piece
like that's you're on the list you can
just click the link you'll have to
highlight it I know but then I open it
in Internet Explorer and then well I'd
rather you open it in Internet Explorer
then just sit here and you know
have your thumb up your ass it feels
like it it smells oh now that one okay
here we go thank God for rah let's go I
sent me somewhere my phone and said it a
whole time I don't know how to hog-tie
people he's not a Boy Scout where'd he
learn the knots from the defense rests
the Pied Piper of R&B I mean hit after
hit decades of success in the music
industry and 2019 has brought you to the
point that you're on national network
morning television bawling your eyes out
saying I don't know how to see that
again
I mean if that's not the greatest quote
that CBS this morning will ever have in
an interview I don't know what is and
he's doing I mean this is the face that
I was talking about yesterday and a
bunch of people on social media picked
it up this is the face that I believe
will beat out the crying Jordan face for
dominance in crying memes mmm this is it
that me somewhere my phone even said it
a halt I mean come on that face with the
context of Oh what was our Kelly crying
about he was crying because he was being
falsely accused of hogtied Pete well
maybe he's upset that he didn't how to
do it he doesn't even know how to do it
embarrass I can't read Your Honor the
defense would like to present Exhibit D
art Kelly's YouTube history he clearly
viewed a hog-tie YouTube video
[Laughter]
to me you do a great job just sitting
there watching this man lose his mind
and going holy [ __ ] greatest thing that
could have ever happened to but she
keeps hitting them two there was two
things that happen in Gayle Kings career
one she became Oprah's best friend to
she got to interview on Kelly she would
go this well no way she thought it would
go it would take on somebody to think
that would go this well he's gonna cry
and throw his arms out and claim he
doesn't know how to hog-tie people no
gonna happen right sorry it couldn't
don't please scream do you think that
this helps to say you think people like
go to his music after this well you know
I don't know doesn't come out in a
[ __ ] helicopter on his next show yeah
she's holding a hogtied puppy - watch
out sorry
let's get back to this is real this is
not a life what kind of woman would tend
to how a dad who's trying to have a
relationship with their kids you know
how many kids need a relationship with
their father
what is unique my god what is your
relationship with your children our
Kelly is sitting there saying here's hi
here's what's going on are Kelly just
loosened his tie he's crying
I mean crocodile tears he's bawling
crying Gayle King is looking at him
stone face you know what's going on in
our Kelly's mind what the [ __ ] do I have
to do to break this woman yes how great
would it be if you just pull that his
dick and pissed on her and she would
questions what is the relationship with
your children just she is hey go back
through that most the most honest moment
he just had was that oh my god like this
is his nightmare that was a very honest
moment this is a guy who believe what
you want to believe there is no doubt
that this is a guy who's become a
professional at using his emotions to
trick women into into feeling certain
way sent and to get people to to go in
the direction that he wants them to go
in to look across from a woman and to be
crying and to be pleading and to be
doing all this no redress from no effect
and she has no Gale is not looking you
know and sometimes women feel you know
right
a little bit like oh my god this guy
she's like she's looking at him like
[ __ ] you you actors zero yeah yeah I
know what you did I still know it I
think his meltdown is real but it she
doesn't give a [ __ ] his meltdown is not
for the reasons that he's saying the
meltdown is for him right yeah it's just
he realized his career is over yeah I
can't believe to end now any also at
this point in the interview I think
realizes that this is not going the way
you thought it was gonna go yeah that
he's not convinced Gayle King cuz he
knows look he may not be the smartest
guy in the world doesn't know banking or
reading or spelling or anything like
that yeah or hog-tie he doesn't know
knots
he knows two things he knows music yeah
and he knows people's emotions yeah and
he knows he is not broken Gayle he's
probably a very good manipulator yes
absolutely
he's a good communicator and I just
can't with her he doesn't care about the
kids crying there you're right Jim it's
not about that no it's more about he's
just realizing the magnitude of what's
happened like and that oh my god is this
it's my nightmare it's here yeah this is
amazing this real next question it's
just gliding down the backwards kind of
cone you know yeah she's just reading
her questions it says here that you knew
she was searching from the back of the
sheet you see that yellow stain starting
to build and she won't stop
[Laughter]
what is your relationship what is your
relationship with your children excuse
me but I know my kids love me I'm in
love with my kids I love my kids let's
see what Gayle had January Kelly's
oldest child who is now 20 years old
wrote in an Instagram post that she and
her two siblings have not had a
relationship with their father for years
we reached out to Andrea Kelly for
comment on our Kelly's allegations but a
representatives say they do not have any
statements at this time Gayle King is
[ __ ] awesome yeah they were
interviewing her Tom call he's great
she's become a big part of the story now
they were interviewing her and it was a
story yesterday that she said this is
when you know you're [ __ ] if you're r
kelly the headline yesterday was Gayle
King says she didn't feel like she was
in danger during the interview and
you're going you are so like art Kelly
is such a villain that the assumption
would be Oh Gayle King must have felt
like she was in danger but Gayle King is
this is this he-man of a woman is this
powerful woman who's sitting there
standing up to this villain of all
villains who can't scare her post on it
was him standing up so all I saw was him
standing on front of her like with his
hand they wanted you to think that you
know he was like she was in some sort of
danger but she was ice-cold man yes I
read it notice some of these some of
these calls here let's go to Brad and
Oregon what's up Brad that clip where he
was like I don't know how to hot tie
doesn't he sound like Sweet Georgia
Brown he does sound like that I think
yeah Rob for tomorrow for your project
over the weekend can you go ahead and
make me an R Kelly soundboard please
thank you very very much Kevin in
Florida hey what's up yeah this
interview so crazy I can't imagine that
somebody who passed the bar exam what
have their client do this so I'm
wondering if it's to like poison the
jury pool or like have a claim for an
council down the road no this is I think
this is because this is him testifying
when he's not under oath you are
poisoning the jewsí jury pool you're
testifying and there's no you're not
bound by being under oath so you he's
not gonna testify in his own trial I
don't think maybe it's like they're
poisoning the jury his lawyer didn't his
lawyer allowed this I don't maybe he's
just like I don't mean that like it
becomes more difficult to have the trial
because they can't find an unbiased jury
I think he's just trying to get his
message out there and again not under
cross-examination but maybe they're
thinking it's like it's like it's like
the Knicks like fans of the Knicks want
them to lose more now so they get the
higher draft pick at the beginning of
the next season so maybe the lawyer is
going like okay halfway through the
interview he's going this is going so
badly that maybe it'll just [ __ ] the
case up entirely so this is either has
to go excellent or horribly yeah so this
is by design that's an interesting
theory I don't think so okay I think our
Kelly had a complete breakdown I think
he envisioned this going very very very
differently very differently I thought
he was gonna I think he thought he was
gonna win over Gayle King leggings done
to so many other women yeah and then
when he saw it not going that way he
just broke he's broke you broke
he broke him yeah instead of even she
broke him I believe wow Eddie in
Pittsburgh yeah hi I was just calling
because I noticed that the interviewer
forgot to ask the most pertinent
questions with all the time that she had
allotted to her was that these girls
have their passports and did they get
their shots that actually is Thank You
Eddie that actually is a very very
important question and hopefully
delivered like Frankenstein's assistant
yeah but still yeah I do and who knows
because we've only heard clips maybe a
Gayle King will ask this pertinent
question in the extended interview that
they are on Friday night but I would
like to know if the girls had their
passports and if they had their shots do
you know this this single and result I
know you're familiar with are Kelly's
cattle or I love it you like this one
live versions Ethiopia have you heard
the song do you have your passports you
know check and check
is over 2009 right now I believe I've no
I think it is from somewhere around two
dozen no this is recent he was just in
Ethiopia I thought this is from New
Year's so it wasn't this year's New
Year's I thought it was no I don't think
Santa might be right it might be recent
I don't think it's this year's New
Year's oh but he went to Ethiopia
it's from 2011 oh but he went to
Ethiopia and yeah well you're wrong on
all counts and this was the song that he
just started singing to the crowd on New
Year's Eve I got it did you get your
shots girl would you like to come back
with the greatest song ever
[Music]
[Applause]
powerful voice amazing
[Music]
is it amazing that he could just sing
about anything and it becomes a song
literally he's got it such a what a gift
to be able to [ __ ] him belt out a [ __ ]
lyric song like that I mean is
recruiting is what he's doing 100% but
it's great that he doesn't like he's too
stupid to as write in metaphor so it's
just very very literal but he's so
talented that he can get away with being
so stupid as a writer yeah it's amazing
I would say that that song probably
wouldn't do our Kelly any favors if it
were played in court I would absolutely
present that as evidence like just so
you know this is the type of [ __ ] he
does in Ethiopia I don't know shots well
yeah come in without the shots so what
do you say do you have your passport
that's one thing yeah when you go as far
as did you get your shots do you want to
come to America that's like I'm really
asking once I go did you get your shots
no I want to know because we are I am
gonna bring some of you back with me to
America somebody back was like you think
we could bring some of these girls back
he's hold on I got an idea I think we